ألقِ نظرة أجنبية على القصة المذهلة
لرياضي متطرف أصيب بالشلل مرة واحدة في جميع
الأطراف الأربعة وهو يضرب الصعاب
ويغزو جبلًا قبل 14 شهرًا بسبب
إصابة في العمود الفقري من حادث تزلج على الجسم
تركت فيشال شوكلا من ولاية يوتا
مشلولًا في معظم جسده.
شيء لا يريد طفل يبلغ من العمر 23 عامًا
سماعه أبدًا والكلمات الدقيقة هي
أننا لا نعتقد أنك ستمشي ، لكن
نقد شوكلا وتصميمه حملاه في
رحلة استمرت أكثر من عام من خلال إعادة
التأهيل الجسدي الصارم
لاستعادة القوة والقدرة على الحركة له.
أطراف من كرسي متحرك إلى مشاية إلى
عكازات إلى معلم جبلي في
تعافيه المستمر بمساعدة
الأصدقاء ، قام شوكلا بتلخيص
أعلى قمة في جبل هود في أوريغون وهو يدفع
تقدمه إلى الأمام في جمع التبرعات
للآخرين الذين يحتاجون إلى إعادة تأهيل مماثلة.